สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 30
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
พ.ศ 2565
ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค.ศ 2022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้ 9 โมง 3 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ 9 โมงเช้าที่บ้านครูเรียมฝนตกไหมคะ
ไม่เลยค่ะวันนี้แบบแดดแรงมากเรียนแบบลืม
ตาไม่ขึ้นเลย
ทำไมอ่ะถ้าแดดแรงเนี่ย
ตื่นเลยแบบว่าไม่อยากนอนไม่ง่วงแล้วเพราะ
ว่าแสงแดดจ้ามากๆใช่ค่ะก็ตื่นนะตื่นแล้ว
ก็แบบลืมตาเยอะไม่ได้
แดดแรงมาก
ลืมใส่แว่นกันแดดได้ไหมใส่แล้วก็คุยกับ
ผู้หญิงไปด้วย
ครูหญิงอ่ะโอเคนะคะแต่ว่านักเรียนล่ะคะ
ถ้าเราสอนไปด้วยแล้วก็ครูเรียมใส่แว่นกัน
แดดไปด้วยได้ไหม
นักเรียนก็คอมเมนต์บอกได้นะคะถ้า 1 ได้ 2
ไม่ได้นั่นเอง comment บอกได้
มีวันนึงที่เรียนแบบแรงริมก็เลยแบบเอาขน
ตาปลอมมาติดค่ะ
[เพลง]
แต่ว่านักเรียนตกใจ
ครูเรียนเป็นอะไรวันนี้ครูเรียนแปลกๆนะ
ก็อาจจะรู้จักเราในวีดีโอใช่ไหมคะหรือว่า
ผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียนอย่างนี้อัดวีดีโอด้วย
กันแต่เราก็ยังไม่ได้รู้จักกันเยอะ
แล้วก็อัดวีดีโอเสร็จก็บ๊ายบายค่ะครู
เรียม
วันนี้เนี่ยก็เลยเหมือนจะมีเกมไม่ใช่
เหมือนจะมีเกมค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยก็จะมีเกมมา
เล่นกับครูเรียมแต่ว่าครูเรียมเนี่ยไม่
ต้องคิดเยอะค่ะแต่ครูเรียมเนี่ยต้องคิด
นิดหน่อยเพราะว่า
ทำเวลาเล่นเกมวันนี้เวลาคำตอบเนี่ยมันจะ
อยู่ที่ครูหญิงไม่มีแบบว่าคำถามแล้วไม่มี
คำตอบที่เป็น ABC ให้ครูเหลี่ยมเลือกนะคะ
แต่ครูเรียมเนี่ยต้องคิดว่าครูหญิงจะตอบ
อะไร
ให้
เรียนทายใจครูหญิงหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่า
ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะทำหรือไม่ทำ
แค่ 2 ข้อเองคือ 2 คำตอบมีแค่ 2 ช้อยส์
เอง 50%  50% นะคะแต่ว่าโดยเวลาที่ครู
หญิงถามเสร็จกลิ่นก็จะเขียนเขียนเอาไว้
ก่อนเขียนเลข 1 ก็คือทำ 2 ก็คือไม่ทำนะคะ
พอผู้หญิงเขียนคำตอบเสร็จแล้วครูเรียมก็
ค่อยตอบคำถามว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะทำใหม่
ก็คือทำใช่ไหมคะทำค่ะทำแต่ถ้า 2 ก็คือไม่
ไม่เอา
ไม่ทำ
พร้อมค่ะ
คิดว่าข้อแรกเนี่ยครูเรียมอาจจะรู้นะข้อ
แรกก็คือครูเรียมคิดว่า
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะจะไปวิ่งมาราธอนไหมคน
อย่างครูหญิงเนี่ยจะวิ่งมาราธอนนะ
เรียนคิดว่านักเรียนก็รู้
จะไปวิ่งมาราธอนไหมคะ
เตรียมตอบข้อ 2 ค่ะ
ไม่
ไม่วิ่งมาราธอน
[เพลง]
นักเรียนก็รู้
มาราธอนเนี่ยโอเควิ่งมาราธอน
1 กิโลอะไรนะถ้าวิ่งมาราธอนเนี่ยเขาวิ่ง
ถ้าเกิด 40
ถ้าเกิด full มาราธอนก็ 40 เท่าไหร่อ่ะ
40 กว่ากิโล
ถ้าเกิดฟูมาแล้ว
ครูเรียมเคยวิ่งไหมคะแต่ถ้าเป็นครูเรียม
ล่ะครูเรียมจะวิ่งมาราธอนไหมให้ผู้หญิง
ตอบไหม
คุยคิดว่าวิ่ง
จริงๆ
[เพลง]
นะแต่ตอนแรกไม่ได้คิดว่าจะวิ่งที่สาวอยาก
ไปวิ่ง
ริมก็เลยอ่ะโอเคไม่มีเพื่อนไปใช่ไหมเรียม
ก็ไปด้วย
ก็เลยซ้อมๆๆ
กลัวตัวเองวิ่งไม่ไหวแต่พอไปวิ่งจริงๆ
วิ่งจนได้รางวัลกลับมา
แค่ซ้อมเพราะว่ากลัวตัวเองจะไม่ไหวนะ
แต่พอดีจริงๆชอบวิ่งเล่นเรื่อยๆ
ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าครูเรียมต้องวิ่งแน่ๆนะคะ
อันนี้ไม่ยากเนาะ
เก่งมากนะคะขอบคุณค่ะ
ข้อที่ 2 นะคะข้อที่ 2 ครูเรียงเนี่ยคิด
ว่าถ้าครูหญิงมีโอกาสนะครูหญิงเนี่ยจะ
เปลี่ยนสีผมตอนนี้ผมสีดำใช่ไหมคะคุณเอ็ม
คิดว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะเปลี่ยนสีผมเป็นสี
เขียวไหม
ผู้หญิงตอบแล้วไม่ยากคิดว่าข้อ 1 ก็คือ
เปลี่ยนนะเปลี่ยนแน่ๆถ้า 2 ก็คือไม่เอา
ไม่เปลี่ยน
เรียนตอบข้อ 2 ไม่ไม่เปลี่ยนไม่
ถูก
เก่งมาก
แล้วถ้าครูเรียนล่ะ
ครูหญิงก็คิดว่า
ครูเรียมไม่เปลี่ยนสีผมเป็นสีเขียวเหมือน
กันค่ะผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าครูเรียนไม่ทำ
ค่ะเอาเป็นสีอื่นได้นะ
เขียวแบบนี้
แต่ดีกว่านะเขียวแบบครูเรียมเนี่ยกับ
เขียวแบบครูหญิงนี่เขียวครูเรียมดีกว่านะ
คะเออใช่ๆอันนี้ได้อยู่เขียวผู้หญิงนี่
แบบน่ากลัวมาก
ข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อต่อไปเนี่ยครูเรียมคิดว่า
อันนี้เปลี่ยนสีผมไปแล้วใช่ไหมคุณเรียม
คิดว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคนอย่างครูหญิงเนี่ย
นะคะถ้ามีโอกาสครูหญิงแน่จะเจาะจมูกไหมก็
คือปกติเราจะเจาะที่หูใช่ไหมคะแล้วอ้าว
ต่างหูกูเรียนไปไหนแล้วล่ะถอดออก
ต่างหูเอ้ย
ต่างหูอันนี้ธรรมดา
ครูเรียมเนี่ยคิดว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะเจาะ
จมูกไหมเราก็ใส่เขาเรียกอะไร
ผู้หญิงตอบแล้ว
จะเจาะจมูกหรือไม่เจาะจมูก
เรียมคิดว่าไม่
ครูเรียมเจาะจมูกอันเล็กๆอีกมันสวยดีนะ
แบบเวลาดูหนังอินเดีย
เจาะจมูกอ่ะรู้สึกแบบเออถ้า 1 วันเรามี
โอกาสก็อยากทำนะ
ผู้หญิงเราเราแบบเอากาวมาติดก็ได้นะเราก็
เอาเพชรมาแล้วกาวทาแล้วก็ติด
มันจะคันหรือเปล่าแต่ไม่รู้ว่าเจาะแล้ว
หายใจจะเป็นยังไงเนาะ
ครูหญิงคิดว่าครูเรียม
ทำไงไม่
ไม่ทำ
ถูกต้อง
ทำไมอ่ะ
ถ้าเจาะแล้วต้องใส่
ใส่จิวบ่อยๆ
ยังคิดว่านานๆดีกว่านานๆก็เอากาวทาเพชรมา
ติด
เพราะว่าถ้าเจาะแล้วอ่ะจมูกมันก็เป็นรู
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วถ้า 1 วันเราเบื่อแล้วเราแบบ
ไม่อยากใส่เอาจิวออกเราก็จะมีรูเลยนะ
อยากทำเลยเนาะแต่ผู้หญิงทำนะนั่นไง
ข้อต่อไปนะคะครูเรียม
ครูเรียมคิดว่า
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
จะกระโดดบันจี้จั้มไหม
นักเรียนรู้จากกระโดดบันจี้จำเนาะที่มัน
ขึ้นไปในที่สูงๆอ่ะค่ะแล้วเขาก็จะผูกขา
เราอ่ะใช่ป่ะแล้วเราก็จะกระโดดแล้วก็เอา
หัวลงมานั่นแหละค่ะ
ถ้า 1 วันได้มีโอกาสไปในที่ที่เขามีโดด
บันจี้จัมพ์แล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยจะโดดไหม 1
ก็คือโดดใช่ไหมคะ 2 ไม่โดดผู้หญิงเลือก
แล้วค่ะครูเรียง
เนื้อข้อ 1
ถูกใช่ไหม
ครูหญิงกลัวความสูงมากคุย
ไม่ไหวๆ
แม่แบบอยู่บนตึกสูงๆอ่ะสมมุติอยู่บนตึก
ชั้น
20 ก็ได้แล้วก็แบบมีกระจกใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
ยืนบนกระจกแล้วมองอ่ะ
ก็ไม่โอเคแล้ว
ไม่ได้
รินก็คิดว่า
ถ้าเกิดครูหญิงได้ทำสัก 1 ครั้งในชีวิตก็
น่าจะทำอะไรประมาณนี้
[เพลง]
กลัวนะคะบอกตรงๆเลยแต่ถ้าเป็นครูเรียงหรอ
ครูเรียนตอบว่าครูหญิงทำผู้หญิงคิดว่าครู
เรียมทำแน่เลยอ่ะ
ใช่ไหม
จริงๆ
เคยเคยโดดบันจี้จำไหมคะเคยไหมยังไม่เคย
โดดบันจี้จำค่ะ
ยังไม่เคยไปเที่ยวที่เขามีโดดบันจี้จำ
ด้วยแหละ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยนะคะเคยแค่
มันก็ไม่ใช่เป็นซิปไลน์อ่ะคือมันเป็น
เหมือนที่ที่เหมือนเด็กๆไปแคมป์อย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะเป็นแคมป์ของเด็กอ่ะเคยไปกับเด็ก
แล้วมันก็มีเหมือนคล้ายๆเป็นซิปไลน์ที่
แบบมันจะเป็นเสื้อยาวๆใช่ไหมแล้วเราก็ลง
ลงมาแล้วก็จะจับไว้อย่างนี้
โอเคเพราะว่าของเด็กมันไม่ได้สูงมากอ่ะ
ค่ะกูเรียมน่าจะประมาณ
2 เมตร 3 เมตรมั้งไม่แน่ใจแล้วเราก็แบบ
ลงมาโอเค
นะแต่มันไม่ใช่บันที่จั้ม
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่บัญชีจำค่ะ
ผู้หญิงกลัวความสูง
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยรู้เหมือนกับว่ามีอยู่
ครั้งหนึ่งอ่ะเคยเดินอ่ะค่ะแล้วแบบมันจะ
มีทางเดินจากออฟฟิศไปห้างแล้วตรงทางเดิน
น่ะค่ะครูเรียมมันจะมีเหมือนเป็นกระจกใสๆ
อ่ะให้เรามองเห็นข้างล่าง
แล้วข้างล่างมันก็น่าจะประมาณแบบ
10 เมตรไหม
ประมาณ 50 เมตร 50 เซนติเมตร 50
เซนติเมตร 50 เซนติเมตร 50 เซนติเมตร
ประมาณครึ่งแบบไม่ถึง 100 เซนติเมตรอ่ะ
คือเตี้ยมากๆอ่ะค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงยืนอยู่บน
กระจกใสๆแล้วมองลงไปข้างล่างก็แบบ
ขาสั่นอย่างนี้แล้วอ่ะ
อะไรที่สูงๆนั่นแหละก็เลยรู้ว่าอ๋อ
เราเป็นคนกลัวความสูงเนอะ
โอเค
ข้อต่อไปยังไม่หมดเวลานะคะข้อต่อไปนะคะ
ครูเรียมคิดว่าครูหญิงนะคะจะทาทาห้องเป็น
สีดำไหมมาอย่างกำแพงห้องเนี่ยพื้นห้องตรง
นี้อันนี้เป็นสีขาวใช่ไหมคะแต่ครูเรียม
เนี่ยคิดว่า 1 วันเนี่ยถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะ
ทาให้พื้นห้องเนี่ยเป็นสีดำไหมคะ
หรือไม่ทา
เรียนตอบว่าไม่
ไม่นะคะไม่ทา
ไม่ทา
ไม่ทาใช่ไหมไม่เอา
ไม่รู้นะว่าทำไมถึงมีคำถามข้อนี้
มันอาจจะเป็น
สิ่งที่คนไม่ทำไหมทาห้องเป็นสีดำอ่ะเพราะ
ว่ามันมืดอ่ะ
ส่วนใหญ่คนจะทาเป็นสีขาวใช่ไหมสีครีมสี
ฟ้าหรือเหลืองๆเหลืองอ่อนๆใช่
เพราะว่าเรียนไม่ชอบสีดำไม่ชอบบ้านสีดำ
เพราะว่ามันจะมียุงเข้ามาในบ้านเยอะๆแล้ว
ก็จะมากัด
ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงก็ตอบ 2 ได้
แล้ว
ไม่ทำแต่ว่าข้อนี้ง่ายอยู่แล้ว
ใช่คิดว่านักเรียนล่ะนักเรียนจะทำไหมทา
ห้องเป็นสีดำ
หรือว่าใครทาห้องสีดำลองส่งรูปมาให้ดู
หน่อย
YouTube  YouTube  comment กับรูปไม่ได้
นะต้องส่งไปให้ครูเรียมนะคะ
[เพลง]
ข้อต่อไปนะคะครูเรียมคิดว่าถ้ามีโอกาสมา
คุยครูหญิงเนี่ยจะสักไหมสัตว์ก็คือมีเข็ม
แล้วก็จิ้มหมึกสีดำแล้วก็
นะคะเป็นรูปหัวใจสักเสร็จแล้วก็จะอยู่
ตลอดไปเอาออกไม่ได้นะ
จะสั่งไว้
เตรียมคิดว่า
เยอะ
เป็นจุดแบบเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
จุดแบบ
จุดเดียวอ่ะ
มันก็ไม่สวยสิถ้าจะสักก็ต้องแบบสวยๆนะเออ
แต่ครูอีกไม่เคยคิดจะสักนะคะแต่ว่าไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้แบบ
ยังไม่ได้คิดที่จะสักรู้สึกกลัวเจ็บเพราะ
ว่าเหมือนกับว่ามันจะต้องเอาเข็มจิ้มๆๆๆๆ
ๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆเรา
เยอะอ่ะ
แล้วคู่เรียนล่ะ
ไม่สักใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่สัก 2 ค่ะไม่สั่ง
ถูกต้องไม่สับ
ทำไมทำไมครูเรียนไม่สับยังไม่เคยคิด
เรื่องจากเลย
ถ้าเราไปซะเราต้องจ่ายเงิน
จ่ายเงินใช่ไหม
แล้วมันก็จ่ายเงินแล้วมันเจ็บตัว
ไม่ทำ
อ๋อก็คือแต่ถ้าสักแบบไม่เจ็บตัวโอเคใช่
ไหมคะทำ
ริมก็เอาสติกเกอร์เรียมเคยเล่นสติ๊กเกอร์
ที่แบบเป็นแผ่น
มาติดแขนมาติดแขนแบบนี้แล้วเขาก็เอาใส่
น้ำ
แล้วก็ทิ้งไว้ประมาณแบบให้มันลื่นๆแล้ว
ริมก็แกะออก
ไม่เจ็บ
ไม่เจ็บแล้วก็อยู่ประมาณ 5 วัน 6 วันก็ถู
ล้างออกได้แล้วเปลี่ยนได้บ่อยๆได้
ก็เราสองคนก็ไม่คิดสักเหมือนกันนะคะมัน
เจ็บ
ข้อต่อไป
ครูเรียมคิดว่า
ครูหญิง
เอาอะไรดี
ถ้ามีโอกาสแล้วก็ได้ไปว่ายน้ำ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะไปว่ายน้ำกับฉลามไหม
ฉลามคือฉลามมันจะมีฉลามที่ใจดีนะคะ
ใช่
เราอ่ะไปว่ายน้ำกับฉลามได้คุณคิดว่าถ้า 1
วันครูหญิงมีโอกาสเนี่ยครูหญิงจะไปว่าย
น้ำกับฉลามไหม
ผู้หญิงพูดถึงฉลาดใจดีมาด้วยนะ
ผู้หญิงเลือกแล้วผู้หญิงเลือกแล้ว
อาจจะรู้สึกว่าอุ้ยใครก็ไม่ทำหรือเปล่า
เพราะว่าฉลามเนี่ยมันน่ากลัวผู้หญิงก็เลย
บอกว่ามันมีฉลามใจดีด้วย
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงเลือกแล้วค่ะคุณเรียม
เตรียมตอบว่าข้อ 1
ทำ
ว่ายน้ำกับฉลาม
ครูหญิงตอบว่า
ไม่ทำ
ผู้หญิงบอกว่ามีฉลามใจดี
แต่
ผู้หญิงก็ยัง
ว่ายน้ำกับฉลามก็ยังรู้สึกไม่สบายใจอยู่
ดีอ่ะครูเรียมพอในความรู้สึกของเรามันก็
ฉลาดมันต้องกินเราแหละถ้ามันหิวขึ้นมามัน
ทำยังไงล่ะ
ก็เลยแบบเออไม่เอานะคะแล้วก็แบบการว่าย
น้ำ
ผู้หญิงก็ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นด้วยนะ
คะ
ครูหญิงคิดว่าครูเรียมเนี่ยทำแล้วกัน
เพราะว่าครูเรียงชอบวิ่งชอบออกกำลังกาย
ไปว่ายน้ำกับฉลาม
แต่ข้อนี้ตอบยากมากเลยนะ
ทำไมอ่ะ
ตอบยาก
ตอบยากนิดนึง
เพราะว่า
เรียนก็รู้สึกกลัวพูดถึงรู้สึกกลัวแต่ว่า
ให้เลือกรินก็จะทำนะ
มันหมายถึงว่าถ้า 1 วันเรามีโอกาสอ่ะเรา
อยากทำไหม
คะทำไมทำยากแบบอยากลองดูใช่
[เพลง]
ลองดูคิดว่าเอ๊ะถ้ามีคนทำได้เราก็น่าจะทำ
ได้นะ
ก็ลองดูว่าระหว่างครูเรียมกับฉลามใครว่าย
น้ำเร็วกว่ากันผู้เรียนจะว่ายน้ำชนะฉลาม
ไหมอันนี้ก็ไม่น่าจะเป็นคำถามได้
มันก็ต้องเป็นอะไรที่แบบว่าให้เราแบบ
เลือกยากๆหน่อยไงนะคะก็เลยมาเล่นเป็นเกม
ทายใจสนุกๆหรอ
แต่พูดถึงข้อเมื่อกี้ก็ยากอยู่นะ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนนะคะ
นักเรียนน่ะทำข้อไหนบ้างหรือว่าไม่ทำข้อ
ไหนบ้างก็ comment บอกเราได้เนาะแต่
วิดีโอนี้นะคะคิดว่าผู้หญิงกับผู้เรียนก็
จะไปว่ายน้ำกับฉลามแล้วนะคะนักเรียนดีมาก
ค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนรอครูหญิงกับ
ผู้เรียนกลับมาอยู่นะคะ
บ๊ายบาย